si j'allais chercher un problème de
flic était un excellent exemple de ce qui
n'allait pas ici à baltimore où
commencerais-je
parce que nous voulons ouais nous voulons courir un
peu hypothétique par là
j'ai dit que nous sommes sur une enquête nous allons
bien  un gros trafiquant de drogue, un vrai [ __ ] de
monstre, d'accord
[Musique]
nous, euh, vous savez que nous gagnons là où il
garde son argent
et nous tombons sur cet argent,
il est juste devant nous, nous
savons juste que nous le prenons
[Musique]
quoi  penseriez-vous que
tout a changé quand ils ont
trouvé cette expression la guerre contre la drogue
avec la guerre vient la militarisation de
la police l'éviscération complète du quatrième
amendement
ils m'ont mis dans une unité composée d'un groupe
des plus grands escrocs de tout
[ __ ]  département il y a tout cet
argent à gagner et je suis en quelque sorte
censé jouer selon le livre avec
ces [ __ ]
jackpot [ __ ]
donc ces flics surpris en train de mentir
et avec leur comportement abusif sont restés
dans la rue ils l'ont fait
si c'est le cas  e fédéraux ou honnêtes l'affaire
pourrait durer des années quel cas dire non
pablo escobar est la police
dans une guerre vous avez besoin de guerriers sur le terrain
descendez sur le terrain vous avez des ennemis
dans une guerre des civils sont blessés et personne
ne fait rien dans une guerre  vous comptez les
corps
et ensuite vous les appelez des victoires
[Musique]
êtes-vous en colère
[Applaudissements]
vous